dans un mois le 11 mai 1987 s'ouvrira au
palais de justice de lyon le procès de
klaus barbie d'ici cette date nous
évoquerons régulièrement et le plus
complètement possible le dossier barbie
mais ce soir je vous propose avec betty
dureau et les détails des préparatifs de
ce procès notamment l'installation
matérielle en cours dans la salle des
pas perdus du palais de justice de lyon
13 heures les news mais 87 s'ouvre pour
la première fois en france le procès
d'un criminel nazi klaus barbie
incarcéré à la prison saint joseph de
lyon depuis plus de quatre ans entrera
ici la salle des pas perdus du palais de
justice c'est le seul endroit assez
grands pour recevoir après travaux les
quelques 700 personnes attendues
journalistes des mois et observateurs
venus du monde entier pour ce procès de
l'un des responsables de la gestapo de
lyon des consignes strictes de sécurité
portique de filtrage à l'entrée de la
salle où l'accusé ne sera séparé du
public par une barrière de plexiglas un
système semblable à celui des aéroports
devant l'accusé son avocat jacques
vergès
en face l'avocat général pierre truche
l'accusation
le président andré santini président
d'assises arbitres et juges du procès
à ses côtés deux assesseurs gérard
becker et pendre et pichery
neuf jurés femmes et hommes tirés au
sort sur une liste d'habitants des
communes du rhône
à la barre se succéderont 45 avocat
parmi eux de très grands noms du barreau
français pour représenter les quelque
100 une partie civile
trois caméras filmeront l'intégralité
des débats pour les archives de france
diffusion au plus tôt en 2007 selon la
loi
il y aura plus de 200 coureurs demain au
départ du 85